[Music]
Okay. So, I'm trying to do the same
thing in suadiwasa. I'm not going to do
another different thing. Okay. Your
angles because I'm not crossing as much
terrain. Your all your angles are going
to be shorter. Okay. Maybe even sharper,
smaller. Try try not to do like these
big things. See, it got soft. You see?
And then this is something else. Okay.
And now I'm chasing him because I went
too long on that angle. Do Do you
understand? Okay. So, I'm here.
Boom. Technique done.
Just want you to free your mind. Stop
traveling all over the mat.
Okay. Same thing here. I'm not moving
way out here. I just need Go
back. I just need that flanking angle to
him. Okay, that's all I'm looking for.
Boom.
Done. Next thing though, it's got to be
the same. Okay. So, a lot of you are
here and you're pushing and he goes to
lay down and you go for it. No, he has
to come around me. He He doesn't get to
go where he wants to go. Not
there. Okay. Make sense?
And then I still have the timing issues.
So,
his head has to keep moving the entire
time, which has nothing to do with
speed.
Okay. All right. So, the mic was muted
on the following clip. Uh, this is what
I was saying. Okay.
Uh, when we come
around
here, a lot of times the UK, especially
the Federite UK, they just want to lay
down.
and then you take
it. We don't want that.
Okay. He h I have to from the new
control
point make his center traverse the
sagittal plane. So when I just do this
when I'm just in this shoulder joint,
you could see his center doesn't really
traverse the mat. Okay. So when when I'm
here like this, I have to make him
traverse the sagittal
plane. Not in the shoulder. I'm still
working with that. He still has to come
around
me. I'll give you a metric to look at.
When you're doing this other thing, his
spine stays on the same vector it was
before. When you're doing it
right, his
uh vector is going to
change. Do you
see? Okay. Was there another point I was
making? That's pretty much it. But was
there any
other clues I gave? You related it I
think it was a sweat. Oh, yeah. The
wrist. Okay. So, what happens here is
you do feel the yong aspect of his
center, but that's what you want. You
don't want to go around it and leave it
there and you're just in the shoulder
here. Okay? It's very similar to when
people
feel, oh, can't move, and then you take
away this. Okay?
the everything is
moving. There's that vector change on
his spine. Okay. Um don't go around Yong
aspect. Internalize Yong aspect. Okay.
That's what you're using to keep control
of him from the limb.
This part is very
important.
Um, so I'll repeat what I was saying.
Okay. What I am
doing
is trying to get that center into the
throw that we saw Andrew take on the
last video. Okay. So, here's the shift
in the difference. And now I start to
blend with the energy that's going that
way in the center. Okay.
The only way his center at speed of life
is not going to be projected is he
counters with the yin yield. Do you see
that? When I feel what is the yin yield
is I would be
displacing through a higher yong value.
Do you see on his body? And what I feel
energetically in the counter is my yong
value is hugely decreasing like
okay and when I feel that I don't keep
pushing on that same center I don't keep
doing that. Okay. This the second I feel
I'm already going for the elbow. Do do
you get it?
Um, and each UK is
different. What I tend to do with you is
I will project your
center enough to
stimulate your own intuitive hyper yin
yield.
Okay? And then as soon as I feel the
yang value, the yang equation changing
value, like as soon, do you see? Like
let's say it was at 10, you were at six.
I'm going to displace you. As soon as I
feel mine go to 9.9, I'm done on that.
I'm not going there anymore. The elbows
open. That's the only way that happened.
Okay, that that's what I'm doing.
Um I'm not trying to throw
him. What you guys are doing is you
either go too far and now the elbow's
not there to catch. Okay, you you missed
the window of
opportunity. Or the worst
mistake is that you never project his
center and you're up in his shoulder
trying to get his body into that tilt.
Okay? And what the point I'm making is
that only works
because he is choreographing the
maintenance of his grip. Okay? So for
example, I'll be the uk and let's
demonstrate. It's in my shoulder. You
see? Okay. If you pay
attention, we'll watch it again. And
you're going to watch my spine upright.
Upright. And now it starts to
go. He goes
upright. I felt his yong. Why don't I
just let go? Do do you
understand on the other one? Boom. Is
that's there. Okay. He did the spinal
displacement and I attack on the spinal
displacement. Do you see? And once the
energy is going that way, I keep the
inertia brings here and pull. I'm doing
that.
Okay. So, we're
like here, let's say.
Okay. And uh you're going to let
go when I uh do the projection. Do you
understand?
Good. But you still saw it.
Okay.
Good. Good.
Okay. So, now we go in
motion. Not Not so good anymore. Do Do
you get
it? Why? Why would you say just
intuitively what
happened? Why did it work after after a
few reps? Why did it
work when I'm there? And why did it not
work this last?
Yeah. Do you guys got it? So the
the basically the reactionary window is
way too it's way too freaking small.
Okay. I might not get EO I might not get
a full throw, but you're definitely not
going to be standing there looking at me
as if I was in the shoulder. Do do you
understand? And I would say I still did
that pretty slow right on the on the
throw part. It just was continuous as it
was going. Okay.
So he could let go and he did, but it
wasn't enough to stop the projection. Do
do you get it? In the other one, he was
upright the whole time until I got into
the shoulder and then pushed his head.
Well, what if he lets go in all that
until that you just have a guy that's
standing there? Okay, does that make
sense?
So careful. You you should be in this
technique. The way to do it as a nag is
that you feel you feel that. Do you get
it? You don't try to do
eil. Got it? You're like, I'm trying to
get his arm so I can get his elbow. You
don't try to do that. You feel the
energy. You'll feel the leakage. and the
elbow will be there. So instead of
training as I say architecturally like
an architect drew these blueprints on a
piece of paper, you're training
uh not in that kind of intellectual
capacity, but you're training in terms
of feeling the energy and experiencing
the energy. Okay? And you have to be
careful when I know you didn't push that
center because it didn't ever traverse
the mat and you're just in the shoulder
and you're unaware that he's only
holding on because of culture and not
because he has no time to not to. And
the best thing to do is to try to just
do that. Okay, got it. So pay attention.
Hi